[Musique]
vous êtes sûr faisant une caté vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir 50 de
transition avant les élections
l'assemblée qui sert d'organes
législatifs pour mali a entériné cette
décision
la junte qui s'entête malgré les
sanctions économiques et diplomatiques
qui pèsent sur le pays nous verrons
aussi sur place quelle est la situation
lendemain de la décision du retrait des
forces françaises
tournée diplomatique de l'expert des
nations unies pour les droits de l'homme
au soudan à damas dhien doit rencontrer
les autorités militaires et les membres
d'associer civils depuis le coup d'état
du 25 octobre dernier la tension ne
retombe
et en ce 21 février journée mondiale de
la langue maternelle nous vous
emmènerons à la découverte d'une langue
déclarée morte par l'unesco et qu'une
femme essaie de réhabiliter au kenya
reportage à suivre
la junte à la tête du mali va pouvoir
rester cinq ans de plus avant que les
prochaines élections soient organisées
l'assemblée qu'elle contrôle a approuvé
par 120 voix pour et aucune contre une
révision de la charte de la liste de la
transition ceci en dépit des sanctions
internationales qui pèsent sur le pays
écoutez ben diarra il est membre du
conseil national de transition
joie et de fierté car les forces
d'occupation quittent par boîte
territoire on ne pouvait que vous avez
juré féliciter le courage patriotique
des autorités précieusement du président
pat le libérateur à ségou but à caen
bartal c'est utile c'est le début de la
fin de la guerre au mali et quand c'est
les forces d'occupation quittent le mali
c'est le début de la fin de la guerre au
mali
et on reste au mali quelques jours après
l annonce du retrait des troupes
françaises les réactions sont mitigées
dans le pays si une partie de la
population malienne s'est rassemblée à
bamako pour fêter cette annonce certains
s'inquiètent du nouveau partenariat avec
la russie et du retrait de barkan du
nord où les populations locales font
l'objet d'attaqués djihadistes au
quotidien sur le territoire dont 2 les
deux tiers échappent désormais au
contrôle de l'état anne fleur l'espion
sur la place de l'indépendance
ils étaient plusieurs centaines venus
fêter l'annoncé du départ des troupes
françaises installé au mali depuis neuf
ans nous sommes dans la joie
[Musique]
c'est un conseil
un départ demandé ici par les
manifestants qui dénoncent l'enlisement
de l'opération barkan et la politique
étrangère de la france au mali la
semaine dernière les autorités de
transition ont demandé le retrait sans
délai des forces par canette à kouba un
retrait dont se félicite certains ici
qui s'est lui les nouveaux partenaires
de l'armée malienne grâce à la russie à
sierre kisangani
il a déjà
quatre membres en partenariat avec la
russie qui inquiète certains au sein de
la classe politique de l'opposition
et sur le plan militaire l'armée
malienne doit être avec qui aujourd'hui
le présent russe a dit l'état russe
n'est pas concerné donc on a affaire
avec une société privée qui viennent
pour leur intérêt pas autre chose ils
vont pas mourir pour le mali et le jour
où on les paiera pas c'est là qu'on sert
à abandonner un playboy malgré la montée
en puissance de l'armée malienne
revendiquée par les autorités de
transition bis soldats ont été tués il
ya quelques jours alors qu'il se
trouvait en opération au nord dans la
zone dite des trois frontières une zone
où des dizaines de civils ont récemment
été exécutés par l'état islamique au
grand sahara pour cet élu de la région
de gao les populations locales font
régulièrement l'objet de représailles de
la part d'eau pour djihadistes qui
opèrent dans la zone des populations
livrées à elles mêmes qui demandent le
retour de la sécurité il faut que nous
mêmes on soit 1 va dire dans l'ensemble
les cours armée le groupe signataires ne
sont pas républicains ce sera très
difficile parce que pour nous la
sécurité il faut connaître les terres il
faut savoir qui est qui dans ce
territoire immense qui échappe
aujourd'hui au contrôle de l'état les
populations demandent la mise en place
nous mais nationale reconstituer prévus
dans les dispositions de l'accord de
paix d'alger
est toujours mali le tchad vient
d'annoncer le renforcement de son
contingent dans la mine isma les forces
onusiennes chargées de la sécurité suite
au retrait des troupes françaises
l'explosion d'une mine artisanale a fait
au moins 55 morts dans le sud ouest du
burkina faso l'information a été donnée
par des sources locales et sécuritaire
qui souligne qu'il s'agit d'un bilan
provisoire ces sources précisent qu'ils
et de nombreux blessés pris en charge
pour leurs deux versions circulent sur
les causes de l'artisan certains parlent
de manifeste manipulation d'explosifs
utilisés dans les mines d'or pendant que
d'autres évoquent l'explosion
une partie d'un dépôt de carburant
l'expert des nations unies pour les
droits de l'homme à damas dhien est à
khartoum jusqu'à jeudi il doit
rencontrer les autorités militaires
ainsi que les membres de la société
civile pour tenter d'apporter une
solution aux nombreux abus des forces de
l'ordre depuis le coup d'état du 25
octobre dernier 82 personnes ont été
tuées par l'armée est beaucoup plus ont
été blessées lors des manifestations
bastien renault
l'arrivée d'adama jianguo soudeur n'a
semble-t-il pas calmé la répression
puisque ce dimanche une personne a été
tuée par balle par la police et que ce
lundi une marche du million ces marches
qui sont censés bien rassembler toute la
population qui est contre le coup d'état
militaire a de nouveau été réprimées par
la police il y a eu à des blessés suite
à des tirs à balles réelles et des
blessés suite à des jets de grenades
lacrymogènes sur les manifestants des
manifestants qui ne croient plus en
l'action de l'onu je vous propose
d'écouter certains d'entre eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
malgré le fait qu'il ne croit plus en
lui il semble tout de même que les
autorités militaires tentent de faire un
pas vers l'apaisement avec l'arrivée à
khartoum de adama dieng puisque 114
personnes qui étaient détenues dans la
prison de kober sans qu'on leur ai
expliqué pourquoi elle avait été
arrêtées ont été transférées vers des
postes de police où on leur a expliqué
les raisons derrière ces arrestations et
où elles auront dorénavant droit à un
avocat l'arrêt des arrestations
arbitraires c'est l'une des demandes des
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme soudanaise ainsi que des nations
unies
mais je puis lance la production
d'électricité du grand barrage sur le
nil après dix ans de travaux et de
controverses avec l'egypte et le soudan
c'est la naissance d'une ère nouvelle a
lancé le 1er mai cégépiens amis achmed
ce 21 février marque la journée
internationale de la langue maternelle
l'occasion de rappeler que les langues
autochtones disparaissent plus de 40 %
d'entre elles risquent de mourir à
mesure que les communautés abandonnent
leur langue vernaculaire au profit des
langues dites globale au kenya une tribu
originaire de la vallée du rift se bat
pour préserver sa langue les yaaku
d'anciens chasseurs cueilleurs qui
vivaient dans la forêt de micros gondo
ont été assimilés par les massaï une
tribu plus forte et plus nombreuse leur
langue a été déclarée éteinte par
l'unesco mais une femme a dû lui a dédié
sa vie il s'agit du yak hunte reportage
de bastien renault
ces enfants apprennent l'oeil account
est une langue éteinte depuis 2010 selon
l'unesco leur professeur fait partie des
trois personnes sur la planète qui la
parlent encore couramment
je suis désormais le pilier de cette
langue cela signifie que je dois lui
être dévoué que je dois tout sacrifié
sans même me reposer une journée car si
quelque chose m'arrive et que je n'ai
pas fait ces efforts la langue montre en
live ses ancêtres par et l'oeil account
et jusque dans les années 1940 mais la
tribu massaï est venu vivre sur leurs
terres à force de mariage la langue et
la culture de yakou à petit à petit
disparu aujourd'hui giuliana et les
siens ton de les faire revivre
selon l'unesco une langue africaine sur
10 risque de disparaître durant la
prochaine décennie giuliana s'est
intéressé aux ja kounté quand elle était
enfant
c'est son grand père qui lui a pris il
est la dernière personne dont c'est la
langue maternelle
voilà une toque et la bloquer
hakim khan a commenté makoto giuliana
multiplie les initiatives pour la
sauvegarde et english et ball paix est à
croquer
cette ong l'aide a enregistré en
dictionnaire audio qui sera ensuite
transformé en applications
d'apprentissage
grâce à la technologie nous pouvons
désormais lié du son de l'image du texte
c'est un vrai avantage
l'application devrait être prête en
décembre 2022 giuliana espère que grâce
à elle et au cou pour enfants deux
prochaines générations de kenyans
parleront de nouveau le diakité
les trésors durée du royaume d'abomey
ont été pour la première fois exposé au
public à cotonou la foule était au
rendez vous pour découvrir les 26,9
restitués par la france en novembre
dernier elles seront exposées au palais
de la marina à cotonou jusqu'au 22 mai
et elles partiront ensuite à ouidah
deuxième étape de leur périple béninois
avant leur destination finale à abomey
mais oui da est une destination
importante pour ses oeuvres nos envoyées
spéciales célia karacena emmanuel sodji
mrm amellal se sont rendus sur place
elle vous explique pourquoi
nous sommes à ouidah la deuxième étape
du périple béninois des 26 trésor du
royaume d'abomey c'est ici dans cette
ville qui était autrefois l'ouverture
vers la mer du royaume d'abomey que ces
oeuvres restituer seront exposés
momentanément les oeuvres en passant par
ridha on ne font qu'un cheminement de
retour vers abu mais un seul mois de
retour parce que
lien à trois corridas et abonnés est
resté très fort à partir de 17h40
jusqu'à la chute du temps c'était pour
un bon mieux relier de domination tu
étais
aussi et surtout la possibilité pour les
monarques du temps aux mains d'avoir
accès à la mer et de converser
directement avec les européens en
éliminant tous les intermédiaires dont
trois au fonds de la famille c'est ici
dans trois mois que les 26 trésor du
royaume d'abomey seront exposées dans
cet ancien fort portugais actuellement
en travaux ils rejoindront plus tard
leur destination finale un musée à abu
mais qui leur sera spécialement dédié
mais c'est sur ces images qu'on referme
ce journal l'afrique merci à tous ceux
qui nous ont suivis de cotonou à ouidah
en passant par abu mais restez avec nous
car l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]